in cape town in south africa
um
the story goes a traveler comes and um
that's that's a watchmaker in town and
all his clocks and watches all show the
same time
you know
so he clearly like invests in keeping
them
and so the traveler asks um
so how do you know what time it is it's
you know it's before the internet like
by a couple hundred years maybe and uh
he said so it's easy up on the hill
there's a fort and every day at noon
they shoot a cannon and then i just set
my clocks to that then the traveler
comes up to the fort and asks how do you
know that it's noon well see i have
these binoculars and in town there's
this uh watchmaker and i just look at
the clock in his window and when it's 12
o'clock i'll fire the cannon
so anyway that passed the time that was
a joke
um
so um but it was funny that when i when
i mentioned that to to my friend last
week
we met up in denmark he said oh oh
that's
that's totally it it's called signal
hill and it's um
and it's in cape town it really exists
anyway
and the canon is 200 years old or
something
still accurate yes yeah
so we are now at 11 40 according even to
um the watchmaker in in in town so um
looks like
i'm about to fire the cannon
uh
again welcome and welcome back i'm uh
mad torguson a masterwizen uh must
have any norwegians in here can you say
it properly for me
there you go yes
i'm not norwegian i i married into this
name and she's not norwegian either but
her gran her her great-grandfather was
so so that's where it comes from
um so if you were here before um like
the last time i gave a talk in here
which you know i do every every second
um time slot i give a talk here that's
that's a deal um i i talked about
functional stuff in in c sharp over the
years now we're going to talk about the
c sharp that's about to come out in six
months time
five months time uh c-sharp 11 which
you know you can you can kind of guess
why it's called that
and when we get to c-sharp 12 we fire
the
um and um
and uh we we're now shipping c sharp
every year
and we decided that okay this is all
driven.net you know they decided every
year now we're modern kind of so so a
year really cadence for major versions
seems about right
um and we're gonna turn the crank use
new numbers for every one of those
every other one of them is long-term
support and all that and we're like okay
i guess c sharp has to do the same thing
so um
so that we can keep that you know
there's different version numbers that's
done so so there's going to be dotnet 7
and c-sharp 11 but at least the delta is
now constant like it's of this you can
always just add 4 to the net number and
you get the c sharp number we're not all
that messy business from back when when
they sometimes lined up and sometimes
went out of whack and you know it's over
and we also stopped saying dot zero
because there's only one time in the
sevens that we ventured into in recent
memory that we ventured into dot
something other than zero so now we just
say c sharp 11.
anyway so so but with this freaking
frequent um
cadence
that more and more what happens is that
we don't drop a whole feature set into
one language version but we kind of
trickle it out over a few language
versions
this first one though is like a
full-fledged language feature being
dropped in all at once
so you see something up here that's
super simple it's
it's a little function that takes an
array of ints and adds them up and
returns the result okay it couldn't be
simpler
still though
up until now
this numeric algorithm
um with a plus in it and zero and so on
there has been no way to
actually
abstract or numeric algorithms and say
no good way anyway to say well um as
long as it has a plus and you know an
additive identity and whatnot you know
run this algorithm
um and um that's always been a bit of a
pain point in c sharp and many other
languages
essentially we can only abstract over
instance members
like with interfaces for instance and
you know operators are not instance
members um so too bad
up until now
so we'll do magic i'll say let's make
this generic
take a t instead
return a t
um
i have a t here as well let's have it
it's t time um
that doesn't work okay it wasn't that
easy um but
you know normally when you want to do
something meaningful with your type
parameters you you use constraints to to
constrain t to
something that offers those meaningful
things so where t something or other and
i kind of want to just say i number
uh well if it's a number and i have to
pass t back in we'll get we can get back
to that
and you know what
it kind of sort of works
like what you're seeing all of a sudden
is that the plus
actually doesn't have a red squiggle
anymore which we all know means it works
um
so
uh
so somehow this interface
guarantees the presence of a plus
operator that's kind of cool okay it
doesn't have zero but kasira really is a
real zero really is a an int right um
but
it has well it has additive identity it
also has zero actually
as a static member on the type parameter
like who'd ever seen that before in c
sharp at least so so
all of a sudden
this interface is bringing in static
members a static property
zero and a static operator plus
in other words interfaces can as
contracts can now specify static members
that's kind of cool right
um
and you know
numbers isn't the
the only scenario that you can imagine
for that but it's certainly a big one
right it's because this whole operator
thing has just essentially meant you
can't do like any advanced
math algorithms into sharp in any nice
way like people have tried and it you
know gets kind of ugly but this is good
this is strongly typed and but but
but how does it work
you know and clearly it's just it's same
old type inference here there's an array
of events we infer int
it probably seemingly then satisfies the
constraint so it implements i number of
of itself i number of int
um but what what is it that you sign up
for when you implement that so let's um
let's go and have a look
here's our number
it's a big type you know it's a big for
an interface in particular it's very
very big it's like i can do all the
number you know if if
uh the um the built-in number types in c
sharp can do it then this interface has
it okay so that's a that's a tall order
to live up to
and not only does it have like a bunch
of members on it but it also has a bunch
of other interfaces that it implements
that bring that each you know brings in
more members
so it's a gigantic interface
but it means that once you once you do
satisfy that then uh you know sky's the
limit you can do all the number and if
that's your constraint then your generic
numeric algorithms can do everything
that you can do with operators and so on
in in c sharp with number types and
t-shirts that's pretty great
and now let's look at these members you
can see they say static abstract
you know
um it's pretty obvious right there
they're static and they're abstract
they're like a contract they're not
implemented
um
and they're static so they're not about
instance members they're about static
members
and
um
the way you implement one is to have a
you know a static
member declaration that would be an
implicit implementation like you can do
with instance members just static
so put your own up implement this
interface yourself put your own operator
implementations on it um that's fine you
can also explicitly implement if you
don't want them to be surfaced
on the implementing type just like just
like other things the only difference is
that they're static
in terms of of declaration anyway
uh we can get back to a little what
what that means
in other ways
so um
but you notice that there are all these
this is long
very very very long at least it's
alphabetical
like you have very sort of orderly need
people on the on the on the pcl team i
think that put these things in
alphabetical order or maybe it's
actually just visual studio that does
that sorting when it shows from metadata
i don't know but
so you saw the you saw i addition
operators there you know there wasn't
actually an addition operator down here
but that's because it's being brought in
from a much simpler interface that we
can go and have a look at that really
just is i have a plus operator and there
are and that now you realize why there
are so many interfaces because there's
an interface for each one of these and
then
that lets you sort of be fine-grained
about uh your constraints if you are
writing a generic numeric algorithm that
just needs plus and zero well you can
just bring in two you wouldn't have to
do i number like i did you could just
bring in
um i addition operators and uh i
additive identity and and then you have
the things you need
uh so that way
because not all when you think about
this this we we're making we're offering
this set of interfaces in the core
libraries so that all our numeric types
can implement them but everyone else can
implement them too and if you're
building
types that use numerics they don't
necessarily have all the bells and
whistles of a full line number right so
so you you want to be able to say for
instance if you're building a matrix
implementation
um
you want to be able to multiply matrices
great so you'll
you'll implement you know
i mult multiplication operator and i
addition operator but a bunch of things
that won't make sense on a matrix
and also in order to implement those you
can make your matrix itself generic and
just say you know where t
some other numeric operators that are
the ones that you need in order to
implement the matrix level operators so
you get this fine-grained control of
like just requiring what you need and
using what you have so um
so that that's why the the interfaces
are designed like that
but this is yeah this is what um
this is what um
an abstract operator looks like it's
it's actually not very surprising when
it comes down to it
so
in
when you want to use these members
though
that is where things get interesting so
back to our program
i am using the members the the the
static abstract members of the interface
not directly on the interface right
because the thing about it like when you
have um
when you have an instance member like i
have something of type
um
object
and i can call tostring on it and
underneath there's an actual object that
might be a derived
class that might not be
instantiated from object itself it might
be string or int or whatever and it
knows its own virtual implementation
because there's an object there to hold
on to like what am i actually going to
do when he says that
but for static members it's different
there's no instance that's a whole point
right so
so we can't just
walk up we can't just have a variable
that's typed i number of t and then go
up and
and call
as um a static abstract member on it
because where would it find the
implementation it doesn't know which
implementation of the interface there's
no instance to ask
so that is where this becomes quite
different and how it works this is the
way that we get sort of an instance
where we get a representation of the
concrete type that we want to get the
implementation for
is with generics
so by taking a t
and constraining it to i number of t
i am saying
there's a type i'm calling it t
and it does implement this interface and
it does have concrete implementations
like if you try to pass a type parameter
that doesn't we're just like
sorry can't do that it has to have
concrete implementations
and
and that's how we get the concrete
implementations through the type
parameter which means that you can only
access these static members
on a generic type through a generic type
through a type parameter you can't do it
directly
i mean you can go walk up to the
concrete objects and call the plus
operator there but you're not calling
the interface member then you're just
calling the static member like always if
you want to access the interface member
you have to do it on a type parameter
constrained by the interface that is how
you get at this functionality so it's
very closely tied with generics
questions
does that imply that if you call with uh
if you call this method once with uh
with double and once with float it will
the compiler will generate two versions
um
yeah um so
the answer to that is the same as it is
for generics today
which is that the compiler the c-sharp
compiler generates just one version
which is generic
um in to il and then the runtime
typically if you're running on a jitted
runtime which most of us are still the
runtime will generate
if it's these value types it will
generate specialized versions for those
value types and a shared one for
reference types so that's that happens
to be the
implementation detail behind it
um
so actually yeah we should i mean i
didn't even show you that you know how
you know i can i can make it i can put a
floating or a double in there and now
they only in the other end convert to
double and the type inference now says
that it's an array of doubles and
everything is still compiled and if you
don't believe me we can actually even
run it
always a little scary i'm not a fan of
running code but um
occasionally you got to do it
there you go i'm sure you you all
can verify that this is the right result
um
by careful like um you know middle
school math
so
um
so that's sort of like
that's the the core of it
you put abstract
static memories on your interfaces you
constrain type parameters to those
interfaces now you can use
the static members including operators
in on on things that are typed t
or around or you know on type t um
now you might be wondering why is it
what is it with this type argument on
the uh on the interface itself what does
it need that for like why why do you
need to have a type argument in order to
have a plus operator
um well again let's go have a look um
the reason is
that
let's say we didn't it actually takes
three the plus of the plus interface
actually takes three right one for the
left
uh upper end one for the right and once
for the result
um
so it's it's parameterized over there
but why does it have one for for itself
so to speak
um
the the reason is that we don't want the
results to be just interfaces right we
don't want to just say well it takes two
i numbers or two i add i addition
operators things and returns an idition
operator because then when you get the
result you've lost the the fact that you
you knew very well what you know what
type it was and now it's it's it's been
delighted you want to use generics to
to pass through
uh the the strong types that you're
operating on so you don't lose
um type strength if you will so
therefore even this one has three but if
you look if you look at i number um
which i just um which i just went away
from that we can go back to um it it
only has the one and that is the that is
the the t self
so um
and that and if you look at all the uh
the um
all the implementations here t-self is
there all over the place because it's
the thing that describes
the actual type that will eventually
implement this interface right the int
the matrix of something that this and
that
it's it's a representation of that type
inside of the interface itself so
therefore it needs to be passed in when
you implement the interface say hey i'm
implementing you and this is me
the and uh and now you can refer to me
with this type parameter inside of your
implementations inside of your
signatures
that's why you see self and input and on
output here all over the place that is
why the plus
in our program
uh
actually it produces a t
um as the output as well that can be
added to the t here that can then be
returned
as an s t to the to the caller that's
how the type strength gets in there
yes
is this backwards compatible with all
the runtimes no
all the runtimes not at all
so you're bringing up a super
interesting aspect of this which is that
up until like while we were still
doing.net framework windows only
the runtime was something we couldn't
touch because it was distributed as part
of windows we couldn't we couldn't know
or influence what runtimes were there on
on people's machines and so
that turned out to be a big
impediment because that meant we
couldn't rely on the presence of new
run-time features in our language
features so we just didn't make new ones
um and um
and then
when we moved over to core we said well
a
we don't
care about uh new language versions
being
um
being runnable on old runtimes
and b
we can now
change the runtimes so that or add new
features to them so that things can be
implemented properly in the runtime like
all the generics in c sharp are in the
runtime and if we did this one outside
of the runtime
it would be different and weird and like
it would be a very bad it would be an
impedance mismatch so we kind of
have to do it to do this feature
um
and um
and we are fine with just saying that
well if you use this feature
and you're targeting an older runtime
which is going to give you a compiler
error all the new runtime features
have feature flags in the
in the bcl
that the compiler is looking for saying
does this runtime
support
static static abstracts and
if if that feature flag isn't there it's
going to say well sorry
you're targeting a runtime is tool this
feature's not going to work
so that's the new compatibility story um
that's the price that people have to pay
for
for getting actual runtime features is
that if they don't have them they don't
have them you know
in a way it's kind of yeah it it sounds
kind of all right when you say it like
that
um
so
um
so uh yeah that's how that works
um
i there's one more thing i want to so i
you get the idea any more questions i'm
happy to take them um at least one or
two more um yes
um yeah i mean the the language doesn't
the language doesn't try to impose
a numeric semantics in any way beyond i
mean it does a little bit today by
saying well if you have a plus operator
it has to like some of the types have to
be the enclosing type and some haven't
have to be the same or whatnot they're
like there's small restrictions and
operators that have always been in the
language but beyond that we don't say oh
we don't try to ensure that you do
proper math with your math operators um
we never did
and
in in a sense just because you're
implementing an interface now we we're
not trying to be more harsh about that
as long as the you know the signature
fits we're like ah that's plus you know
even if it breaks all the rules um
and um
that's just like
that's what we can do
uh the there there is like one
sort of like a get out of jail thing i
use sometimes which is that i mean these
interfaces are in the bcl
and so will be widely distributed you
could write a roslin analyzer that finds
implementations of the interfaces and
tells people
that does not look right you know this
view if you if you're smart enough you
can draw the code to as much detail as
you like with the rosslyn analyzer we
did not do that we
i'm not sure we even thought about it
and i think it probably will be hard for
some of the operators to say you know it
looks this looks like a good
implementation or this looks like a bad
one i think testing is probably better
for that
hey but you could write your testing
code generically actually you could hey
write a test suite
for uh for uh math implementations um
that's completely generic and then when
somebody comes with a new concrete type
that implements it you just run it all
and say hey hey sorry but you had you
identity was not an identity yeah you
screwed up and
so
actually that would be possible as well
so
there are several possible answers to it
but the the honest answer is we have not
done anything in that direction
okay
i want to say one more thing about the
language feature i've been focusing a
lot on math because that was really the
driving scenario that was the thing that
made us
do the hard work
and it is hard work to put a new
abstraction mechanism into the runtime
uh that was one where we felt it was
worth it uh but
that said the language feature itself
has nothing to do with math it just has
to do with abstract static members and
interfaces
and there are actually
there are actually many design patterns
that you can imagine doing more simply
using this feature
one of them is actually let's go to
i-number one of them is
is factories
so actually one of these interfaces up
here is a factory um
i i'm just going to go through the
alphabet here quickly actually not so
quickly
crap okay grab it and run there we go
i i am i
parcelable there we are i parsable
um let's go and have a look at that one
for a bit and it's a little com complex
because you know it has two methods
um and it takes an i format provider but
really what it's doing is it's a it's
prescribing a static method
that will take a string and create one
of these guys one of the t-cells type
right so it is a factory
if your type has this
implement this interface then it is able
to produce its an instance of itself
from a string
right so now we can abstract over a
factory that means this could not have
been done with an instance method
because the whole point is you don't
have an instance yet you want to make
one and now you can have
abstract static factories you can take
like remember all those like so people
who've been going down the rabbit hole
with factories they have these parallel
hierarchies of factory objects to create
the hierarchies of actual objects and
it's like a mess people do it a lot in
java they don't do it so much in c-share
for some reason but um but you see it
and you understand why people do it you
don't have to do that anymore now
because you can just
just
have um
you know um an abstract factory on the
root
a root interface
and um
and um then everything will need to
implement that and that means you can
create them abstractly you can abstract
over the fact
that they have a factory
um so you both have abstract factory and
static factory in the same go static
abstract factory
i think that's very cool and and um
we already are finding places where this
pattern or other of the original design
patterns can sort of be improved upon
even in our own code we we have an
example where we are using this for the
strategy pattern already in some
implementation detail and
so i think it opens up a new world that
we haven't even really explored very
much of
ways that you can abstract that can
reduce complexity of your code
where you really want
that
unified abstraction of things but they
don't naturally show up as instance
members so you can't do it now you can
okay
so that's the i talked about it for a
long time but it is the biggest feature
and this is about how much time i i
expected to spend on it because it's
that is like the one that is
okay since generics this is the first
time we added a new abstraction
mechanism to the runtime so okay this is
big
um and it wasn't it was a bit hard
so i want to spend some time on it to
sort of justif you know
it's really important for you
so with that um
let's leave those behind um go and
and take a look at our numeric algorithm
here and then look at a different aspect
of it it's very imperative
you know it's old style have an
accumulator
zoom around a loop add the stuff um and
then return it super imperative
um we could
try to do it more functionally this is
kind of like also a capstone on the
previous talk then it's like where did
pat where did we go with patterns so one
way
we could also implement this would be
via pattern matching um using the new
list patterns that are in c sharp in c
sharp 11. so i'm actually going to just
do it as i'm i'm going to be brave and
i'm going to start out as an expression
body function here it's going to be
no statements will be used in this you
know it's completely organic
so let's take the values
that's what we have and let's switch on
them
into a switch expression
boom and put a semicolon and this is our
implementation and now
um
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this list this list like thing like
list patterns work on
anything that has sort of the right
surface area
um
and we can talk about what that is if
you're interested in drilling in but uh
and then we're gonna just uh look at the
structure of the list using essentially
list destructuring with list patterns so
the first case uh the sort of base case
is hey there weren't any values okay
well then the result is probably you
know it's probably not multiplicative
identity actually it's probably like
it's probably zero
or you know additive identity would
probably do the same thing so that's one
case in the pattern
that's an empty list pattern or a
non-empty list pattern it could be
so now we're putting patterns inside for
each element in the list so i could say
var
t here for the for the first t
and i could you know put more and if we
want to start simple we can just say
okay let's deal with the case where
there's one element in the list so this
will match only a single element array
um in that case you know yeah you would
just return t that's the sum of t yeah
okay so far so good and we could keep
adding
two three four but you know we're never
gonna get all the way
um
you're not gonna like the feature very
much if that's how you do things
so
so we're gonna have to i mean we're
gonna have to go all the way into
functional land and go recursive here
that's the only
and that means we're going to have to be
able to grab like a rest like
get the rest of the list
so i can pad and match on the first
element maybe and then i can have
uh the rest just dot dot if i don't care
about it or dot dot var
rest or tease
um
and um and that will then give me like
this gives me an a t but this gives me
an array of t that it gives me back the
same kind of thing that that i came in
with
so here be dragons from a performance
standpoint because it's going to give us
a new array that's almost as big as the
previous one
so oh
um but we can fix that in a little bit
um
but um
but so this this one and actually it
doesn't have to be the last it you can
have things after you could have t2 here
uh of rt2 um and by the way these things
can be other patterns as well i'm just
using var patterns to just extract the
values without uh doing any pattern
matching on them
uh so this is totally fine they'll just
grab whatever is between the elements in
front and the elements in back so you
can only have one dot dot section in
there um but you get to decide where i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna have something
after i just wanted to mention that it's
not like restricted like that
um and if we have that then what we
should be doing is we should be adding
the t
to the add all
of the t's
and uh call recursively and now we get
like a lot of reallocation and copying
going on and so
you know there'll be dragons the reason
why is that the um
the way that this actually the dot dot
thing here works like you can imagine
what what is it actually doing to those
list like things when it is getting the
values
you know here obviously it's indexing
right this is index zero if i had one
out here it would be index
hat one or hat zero you know the uh if
you have looked at the hat syntax or
indices
so that's you know that's just indexing
um and to get these it is using um
the ability of that um type to slice so
if it's sliceable
and we already have defined that in a
previous version of the language like
you can have an index so that is you
know x dot dot y and then it will slice
those elements out or throw if they
weren't if if it was out of range so we
already have a notion of sliceability in
the language you may or may not have
seen but just trust me on that
and each type gets to define its own
what does it mean to slice me
and and the sort of design principle for
slice is that it will return the same
kind of thing
that that that came in that you're
calling it on
so if we want to do this more
efficiently we should we should slice
we should have a type that is more that
is cheaper to slice that's not array and
and we have uh
this is not used very much in in top
level code but for performance reasons
we have a type called span of t we also
have a read-only span of t if you don't
want access which is really like a view
on a segment of of memory for instance a
part of an array
and and slicing for spans is super
simple because it's really just a start
and a length so you just you know
we move the start and reduce the length
to create the next one and there and the
value type so we don't even allocate
that little that little uh structure so
so and
and the nice thing about um
i don't know oh this is one of the this
is because i'm in a preview i've run
into this before um don't worry about it
it'll still compile
right
let's just check now let's just check no
what is my problem you can't infer
uh
you know maybe because oh i don't know
never mind we'll just pass it in
oh double
and i'll yeah sorry about that it's
probably simple um but uh i'm on stage
so i can't figure it out
um
so um
uh
the the nice thing about span is that
arrays have a simple conversion to them
a simple implicit conversion from an
array to a span that covers the whole
array so that that would be a way to
make it efficient
so
um the way that
in a functional language this would
typically be very efficient is that
they typically use linked lists
and so if you're careful to slice off
from the front
uh
and oftentimes you know list patterns
would only allow you to slice off from
the front then there's already like a
list
you know it's already a linked list
of the rest that they can reuse
but here you get more expressiveness in
terms of where you slice but you also
have to be more careful in terms of
performance
okay
and of course uh patterns
patterns eagerly check that you cover
all the cases and that you you don't do
uh stuff that can't be reached so if we
so until we had that one the the there
was a warning on switch that would tell
you like you weren't covering
lists longer than one
and
if i took this one which covers
all
lists including
the one with one element and i move it
up
then we get an error on this one saying
hey the one element case has already
been fully covered so so this so you
can't
match it again here
so these are this is this is standard
functionality of patterns already but it
also just to show that it works well for
list patterns as well
so we can actually just delete that one
because it's handled very nicely here
so that's list patterns um there's a
question or two
there
not the span
why wouldn't it be possible to specify
instead of fire in ts
have either array segment or span of t
there and then let the compiler
take an ass span behind
um
[Music]
it's possible we could do something like
that yeah i would i kind of have to see
it worked out a little bit to see if
that will be possible
again and yeah an option is to have tool
support for telling you
hey it looks like you're doing a lot of
slicing on arrays
maybe you want to
fix the code like this and
have it be like an ide
gesture
a warning or a suggestion
um but that's definitely yeah typically
when they're dragons like that it's good
to have some way for either the compiler
or the tooling just to help you avoid
the pitfalls
uh one more take one more
why should you prefer to
in this case i mean it's in
this case it's maybe overkill
pattern matching
just
generally
tends to lead to more readable code
also as you saw it gives you more
checking that your logic is so so
uh
compared to what you had before which is
very imperative it's hard to like tell
am i off by one am i you know doing all
the right things and pattern matching
when it gave you the it gives you the
completeness and subsumption checking
there uh it's just keeping you more
the compiler is helping you
more with correctness
also this combines with all the other
kinds of patterns like all the recursive
kinds of patterns where you can have
patterns within patterns
and so it's kind of a place where
if i'm using patterns to destructure
something a structure
and i get to a collection kind of thing
and i want to do collection like
destructuring on it i kind of run out of
steam now and i have to take the i have
to grab it and take it outside of the
pattern matching
context that i'm already in and this
lets you stay in pattern matching mode
when when you get to those situations so
those are some of the some of the
arguments we'll take okay we'll take one
more
yes
the the the the
the point is this will give you stack
overflow at one point uh at some point
and that is also true like i'm not say
essentially i'm not really here to
advocate uh recursive algorithms
um
it was just like a small a small example
that is familiar to to functional people
but yeah we do we are not able to do
tail call optimization on things like
this and and promise that and make sure
that the stack doesn't overflow this
wouldn't even necessarily be a tail this
isn't even a tail call and so you're
like um
and if they're exception handling so we
don't we don't do that kind of we're not
that functional
and so
you have deep recursion you have deep
stacks that's that's the c-sharp way and
if you're if you have if you have a
domain where you might go very deep
you'll run out of stack
now oftentimes the places where
recursion is good in c sharp they're
typically where you're recursing over
some data structure and then you have
much more of a handle on how big how big
it can get that you know your data
structure is not probably not going to
be all that much bigger than the stack
or you know
it will be more on the same order of
magnitude so so there it makes more
sense
okay
um so that's list patterns for you
let's switch gears and go talk about
persons again like
i can't remember the last time i talked
about new c-sharp features and didn't
have a person class
so it's kind of um it's kind of
traditional this time though i'm going
to change it into a
a person struct just you know shake it
up there you go christmas truck
um
you notice that that's fine
and um for people who have worked with
many people don't work with structs but
if you work with structs and you look at
this for a bit you'll be like why is it
fine actually that would be an error
here in c sharp 10.
the reason is that since
since the dawn of time
for structs we have required
constructors to initialize everything
like if you have a constructor instruct
it must initialize all the fields
and we meticulously check in the
compiler and say
yep you didn't initialize that one not
in a way that i can see anyway so error
and um
and we're like well
why why are we doing that again
um
maybe we're trying to
not
bulk zero initialize things for
efficiency maybe
but couldn't the compiler if it's
figured out that you're not initializing
it couldn't just go and zero out that
one instead of telling us that we're
dumb you know couldn't he just do it for
us i'm like
that must be a deep reason we went and
talked to anders heilsberg he's the like
oldest c-sharp designer around and like
what is the deep reason anders what was
the wisdom behind this he's like i don't
know
i know
it doesn't seem important
okay we'll do it we'll we'll we'll fix
it
and this is and this is important now
because we've done many more things
recently to make structs more versatile
we made them able in c sharp 10 they're
able to be records they're able to have
primary constructors and all kinds of
things where we keep running up against
this limitation you keep doing something
and you get this error and you have to
have to do stupid stuff we let you have
initial field initializes instructs now
and again
once you have a field initialized but
you don't have it on everything then
you're like well then you get slapped
for all the ones that you're not
interested
let's just fix this instead instead of
chasing all these weird corners of the
language
and we do have actually if if for some
reason you really like
pain
you like this error i mean some people
like i i want to make sure the compiler
doesn't do anything for me because it
takes it wastes valuable time or
something and i know what i'm doing
famous last words um we actually do
produce a diagnostic in the
in the in the wrestling computer in the
compilation tree and you can and it has
a diagnostic number like cs
some number
that we produce whenever you do not
initialize everything manually then we
do initialize it for you we still
produce a diagnostic it's just not a
warning error like it's just an info
and but you can go make it an error if
you want to so because it exists because
the compiler puts it in you can raise
that level to warning error and you can
get back your pain
because we weren't entirely sure people
i mean some people
there might be reasons we hadn't thought
about let me just put it
so we're back to classes though um
um we we did a few more things uh around
class like for the last
um for the last couple of years we've
tried to make
we tried to be serious about
immutability and value semantics for
classes as well where you can have like
still have class hierarchies and that
and the sort of class level
expressiveness still having to be
reference types so they can be recursive
yet have value semantics as opposed to
object semantics and that's again sort
of the functional vein of i actually
want to work with immutable data
and and the language has been fighting
on every every step of the way and
and uh we are trying to remove some of
that pain of of when you're trying to go
in those directions in various ways over
the years one is records which we've
done nothing new with records since
teacher 11 so i'm not going to go there
but
um i mean the pain of
having to have constructors
is is uh is an obvious one right and
and
an alternative to having construct let
me just go and and comment out my code
here so i
so that i can um use top level
statements over here instead um
the uh
you know if i if i want to say var mats
equals new
maths because it's immutable i in the
past i would have had to use a
constructor i couldn't use an object
initializer
and
but the but the constructors are just
really super painful i have 2f2 because
the middle name is optional but optional
parameters have to go on the end but i
don't want the middle name to be at the
end and the last names are in the middle
i mean so so i kind of i have to have
this overload and now okay now i want to
create class student or employee or
whatever and it's a person i haven't
even done anything yet and i'm already
in debt right oh yeah you have yeah
you've gotta you have those constructors
you gotta deal with that so it's like
constructors are painful in many ways if
you have hierarchies or several
overloads and sometimes you just want
things to be easier and object
initializers are a way for that to be
easier to just live without live without
constructors but they lack certain
things and in uh what was it c sharp
nine
uh like so one of the things they lack
is
or they used to lack was that if i have
an immutable data structure you know
they they rely on mutation so if i say
first name
name
oh newman's
i'm not a class yet and you know 25
years microsoft they turn you into a
class but i'm not i'm not that guy
first name equals meds let's just stick
with that um
you know um
it says you can't because uh sorry it's
uh it's uh actually
getter only and then we said let's add
this kind of setter that only works in
object initialize it's calling a knitter
and so you might have seen this all this
before because that's not new but it's
just part of the story that i wanna i
wanna get us to there um
and
and that kind of took care of the
initializing immutable things with
object initializes the next thing though
is that i don't want people to
not
give a first name and a last name in
this object model at least i know that
it's not a good object model for names i
should you know remember to say that but
you know
this one can you know it's okay if they
don't initialize middle name but i want
them to initialize first and last name i
want to force them to do so i could do
that with a constructor i was doing that
before there was no constructor that
didn't so there you know so that's one
place where object initializers still
kind of have a gap of expressiveness and
that kind of interferes in an annoying
way with nullable reference types as
well because you're seeing these
warnings here on first name and last
name and what those warnings are saying
is you're not initializing this
non-nullable
property which means it might be null
when the object is initialized
yeah but i want my i want people to do
it themselves yeah but
you can't be sure they will so i'm gonna
give you a warning
um
now
what we really need is a way to ensure
that they will like we're gonna we're
gonna
give you a hammer to say this is
required this is required you can't not
you can't not do it
and now the warning goes away because
it's like yeah you're making them do it
i'm good i'm i'm good now that this will
not be null because when if they go and
put null in they will get the warning
and it'll be their problem you know so
this fixes the nullable problem and this
also just fixes the general problem of
i couldn't force i can force it that
difference in expressiveness so now i
made last name required but i didn't do
it i get an error everything's good it's
just hunky-dory
you can't do this in the previews yet i
think because it just came out in the
internal preview that i'm using that
um
but um
but soon soon or maybe you can't was was
there somebody here you you it is out in
the public preview
yes
the attribute that we use under the hood
to put the required on things isn't in
there
so but but you can cheat and go and so
i've done that there's like a a file in
here that has a declaration of that
attribute and that's why it works here
so this is how it's going to work um
and um and of course then yeah
when i actually get a last name
um
[Music]
it's going to be happy and these are
inherited
obviously so the cumulative down through
inheritance hierarchies
if you have a constructor that is like i
don't want it to do it here
um i it's a good example it's a copy
constructor i'm literally i'm you know i
have an immutable data type i want to
actually create the next record from ads
like um
and i want everything to be the same
except what someone optionally chooses
to put in an object initializer because
they explicitly want to change it
that shouldn't that constructor
shouldn't force everybody to put
everything right it shouldn't force them
to call me mads again that the
constructor just did that
so there's a there we talked for a long
while about what is what should be the
granularity of opt-out mechanisms for
that and we in the end we just ended on
an attribute which is also not there and
i can't show you because i can't
remember what it is and i forgot to
declare it um but there's an attribute
that you can put on a constructor to say
this one is exempt from requiredness
completely so it's all or nothing you
get all the required and none of the
required and none and none of the
required is no worse than today it's
just um
that's the fallback if you if you know
what you're doing
and so uh so we figured that was the
right balance but if if we need more
granularity in the future hey there's a
next version coming next year and you
know we can always make it better
now we can granularly improve features
we can take the the the cautious
approach at first and then
and then when we find out hey
we may need a little more here
it's actually worth it many customers
reporting
then we'll just do it
okay
so that was required there's one more
pro oh yep one question
thank you so much you're welcome
this does not change what constructors
get generated
now
and it also it doesn't
the required restriction isn't isn't
maintained through reflection we talked
about like how can we make that actually
a strong requirement that even works
through reflection like when you have a
serialized or something using reflection
to create the object and we're like
actually read only isn't even enforced
during you know through reflection so
why should this be it's like yeah all
bets are off when you go that
in that direction
um
four constructors that
people generate for specific purposes
like like that they could slap that
attribute on if they if they want to
not require
object initializes to be used
um let's take a couple of questions now
and i do have two more features to go um
can we take them after
all right i'm i'm gonna just stay here
while everybody else goes and grabs all
the good stuff at lunch or we can walk
up together or something but yeah i want
to get to the last two features
apologies
one that i want to show quickly is i
you know it turned out auto properties
turn out to be really awesome because
very often you really just want a
backing field and you want to read and
write from the vacuum field and done
but the moment you want to do just a
tiny little bit thing more you fall
completely off the cliff and you have to
declare your own backing field and you
have to implement all both of your
accessors yourself like there's no
middle ground and we are introducing the
middle ground and what and we do that in
form of field access that you can access
the backing field from an auto property
using the innovatively named keyword
field
um
and
this is not in my prototype yet so
there's going to be squiggles but um
this is what it's going to look like so
so what the set or init
accessor is generated to do is just to
take the um
you know the backing field which we can
now name field and escape out of all
those
suggestion uh suggestions for completion
equals value right that's just what it
does
uh if but what if i wanted to just you
know trim it yeah i don't want white
space accidentally in my first name
now you know i would fall off the cliff
before but instead i can implement the
emitter manually just by referencing the
backing field with the keyword field i
don't have to use the getter or to
implement the getter myself i don't have
to to declare the the backing field so
um it's more of like an incremental
um incremental step instead of falling
all the way off of the cliff
and um and we do the right things if you
know that give questions about does it
do the right things yes it does the
right things
so that's coming um i don't know what
preview but
everything else i've shown so far you
can actually go try
just using the bs previews
but um but not this one yet
here's another one um
uh oh actually it's not here because i'm
going to show it in i'm going to show
this in
in my favorite browser
using um sharblab which if you don't
know sharblab it's awesome it's a
community
uh run website that
that offers up all the latest branches
of the c-sharp compiler um
you know in an interactive way that you
can play with it
and i'm just using main because we did
merge this feature um but in here is a
lovely menu of like all the stuff we
ever did um some of it is broken but um
that's the risk you have it means
even if a feature is not out you can
still use it here and maybe i think
possibly the um
the the field access thing that i showed
before you might actually be able to go
in and try it here but i haven't tried
recently
what i want to talk about is raw string
literals so there's a bunch of times
where you just want to have some code
in a string
in your code you know and it can be c
sharp code oftentimes it's um
oftentimes it's like um
are you also distracted
it's kind of it's kind of cute it's cute
do you have it do you have a cat in your
pocket or is it just a phone
no it's yeah
okay nice
it's very gentle i love it um
you know code can just be xml or json or
whatever the main thing the main problem
about it is it'll have a lot of
characters and the way
what i mean by code is something that
has characters in it that's going to
confuse be confused string literals like
backslashes like that look like escapes
but they really really just want them
and the and the pain of converting
things so that they will end up being
the right thing
uh after the literal husband it's just
like everybody knows this and even like
vibrating strings don't fully solve this
so we wanted to create a new yet another
form of string level and c sharp
that is that has no escapes period there
are no escapes you cannot escape
um and the way we do that is that we we
make you put at least
three double quotes
on either end
and now you can see the backslashes they
they show up correctly they're no longer
escapes so actually i want to remove
them because they don't actually belong
in the content so now what's in there is
just the content that i want no escapes
that's nice well okay somebody's like
what if i have
three quotes
in my content
oh you got me oh what am i gonna do
i'm gonna put four
what if i have 16 quotes
i'm gonna put 17.
you can always win
it
it might not look nice by the time you
win
but the only reason you would have 16
double quotes in a in a sequence in in
you know
in content is because you want to
capture a demo of this feature in in
you know as a string
you know actually i have this i have
this as a constant string in code
somewhere and it you know it has to use
it has to use four quotes because it has
the triple quotes in there um
so
uh usually three is enough but you have
in you you have an escape that's not an
escape if you know what i mean
um these can be multi-line uh and if
they're multi-line you have to like have
a new line both before and after the
content
and that new line is not part of the
content that is part of the delimiters
um so the content here is still like it
has no new lines in it
um but it's now multi-line it's one
multi-line but we can start you know
breaking it over lines
and
well let's do one there as well hello
there we go
um
and um
you might notice that well you just told
me that we just get the raw content but
i'm noticing that some white space is
going missing here
yeah what what's with that are you like
are you cheating here at what's going on
so
what what is it that
let me yeah i mean happens
would actually probably want to indent
this and and a little bit and what you
see is that that indentation gets picked
up so what is going on here like what
what what white spaces are in and what
white spaces are out what's the deal
here
the
the reason for it is obvious is like you
it's really it really it's really
annoying when you're quoting multi-line
things and they flush completely to your
left margin right
and all your code flow is up there and
then something bad it takes all the
attention and it's even red it you know
and then just strangle around it takes
all the attention by being out it's like
just
looks stupid
and so it's really nice if you can avoid
that by just having the white space
clipped off but what if i don't want it
clipped off well we got
something for you as well what's that
more quotes no
no no we're done with that
but um
but the
the way we do it is that the the number
of white spaces before the end quotes
is what determines how much get cut gets
cut off
so if i move this to the left you see
that i get one white space in there and
there and there if i want the full thing
i just flush the end uh quotes all the
way to the left and i get all the white
space
does it work the other way interesting
let's try that's a good thing about
interactive stuff here let's go one over
ah no sorry you can't do that
no no it's like what are you doing
exercise for the reader
um
good one
so
[Music]
now
that quoting is great having like actual
good literal raw literals is great but
what if you do want to interpolate just
a little bit we want to yeah we still
want to stick some content in there like
uh can i interpolate these
you know if because if because no
escapes right so if i put something in
here that's like three plus four that's
just content
you know just content what if i want to
interpolate well i can do that
let's put a dollar sign
and now it's interpolated now the the
single brackets the limit a whole and
the expression inside gets evaluated and
to strength back in
awesome well
what if i want
interpolation and curlies
have you been at this talk before
now they're now their content again
because it takes the dollar signs number
of dollar signs is the number of curlies
it takes before it's instant
interpolation
and now it's a little ridiculous but it
is actually like
it's super useful now we can do this
i have a problem like getting it too to
click in the right place here um now we
can do this and it's interpolated
but if you only have single ones you
know the content
or if you want your single ones around
the interpolation
that's fine too
and then you get you know single quotes
around that if you want double quotes
around there you know what to do
add a dollar sign use three for the
interpolation hall and then you can put
your two and they're not an
interpolation hole anymore
so you can still win
and
i mean i'm
i'm making it a little hilarious here
and you're like
you can see how this can get a little
ridiculous but the important thing is
we are not
forcing you to change things when you
want to quote them
we're just
maybe making you put a lot of quotes
around them so you don't have to go and
find those escapes and you don't have to
to
read the fine print of your output and
we're still allowing interpolation even
when you want curlies like you should we
are not falling for the temptation to
put escapes back in even when it's even
when it's interpolation
so hopefully this is one that is this
one for the ages this is the one
this is the one that is going to let you
quote all the things
uh forevermore that's the planning and
that was the last feature i was going to
show today
which is lucky because we're actually
we're at the end of time
i can take one question
yep
what what sorry
what if you want the string to start
with a double quote
um
you use the multi-line
version of it even if it's just a single
line because then the quotes
on the on the top line here are part of
the delimiter and the quotes on the next
line are the first part of the content
that is why we don't use the new line
as part of the content you know the
content starts
here and ends here so you can do tricks
like that same at the end right
there's always a way
or at least i haven't found a hole yet
and with that i want to say thanks it
was great um great questions and i'm
still around there's going to be lunch
i'll be around there somewhere um if you
have more questions more ideas you know
grab me now
shoot me an email later i'm just mad
stop targeting at microsoft.com i don't
mind sharing that um just with my
closest my 100 closest friends um
i know some some number um
and um and i hope you enjoy c sharp 11.
thank you
you